[Music]
tonight new york governor andrew cuomo
and his team
are in full-on damage control after it
was revealed that they intentionally
misled officials
about the extent of covet nursing home
deaths to avoid the scrutiny
of federal investigators and even fellow
democrats are now coming to terms with
this reality
you have now in new york a group of
democratic state senators demanding
friday that governor cuomo
be stripped of his emergency authority
to deal with the virus
now we sent our own lawrence jones to
talk to a family
one of many as a matter of fact maybe as
many as 15
000 who lost a loved one in a new york
nursing home
and get their reaction to this new
development lawrence l.j how are you
good evening sean new york governor
andrew cuomo received a lot of praise
during the pandemic for his press
conferences
he even received an emmy now he's under
fire after new evidence emerged of the
his office concealing covet 19 nursing
home numbers
i talked with robin hepworth who lost
her mother-in-law
here's what she had to say was your
mother-in-law
concerned when they were bringing those
patients
in the nursing home did she stress
wanted to be moved or
what took place when she started to see
that happen she was
absolutely in tears crying on the phone
to me and my husband every night saying
i'm going to die i'm going to die how
does it make you feel
that when your mother-in-law expressed
that there were covet patients
in the nursing home and no one did
anything about it
very very sad very angry you know
we really didn't even get to say goodbye
to her we didn't you know we weren't
able to have a proper funeral who do you
hold responsible
for your mother-in-law's death i blame
the nursing home
i blame cuomo for you know letting the
infected patients come into the nursing
home
there were people dying in the nursing
home that my mother-in-law had told me
she actually called up me and my husband
saying that she's scared
should cuomo resign yes he should be
impeached yes he should be impeached
if the governor was standing right in
front of you
what would you tell him it's a disgrace
and he needs to resign
i mean to lie to all these families you
know he just kind of makes you wonder
what his agenda is
sean attracts his story legislation was
put in place to protect
the nursing homes from being sued there
was an investigation by the attorney
general
many are asking will there be a federal
investigation
so the governor and his office and the
nursing homes
can be held accountable back to you sean
all right lj lawrence good to see you
thank you now earl